>>> WELCOME TO HANNITY.
DEMOCRATS WANT THIS TO BE
JANUARY 6TH WEEK, BUT THEY WILL
NOT GIVE YOU THE FULL STORY.
BY THE WAY, THERE IS A LOT OF
CONTEXT AND TEXTURE AND A LOT O
THINGS THEY WILL NOT BE TELLING
YOU ABOUT.
TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE VITAL INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH,
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 4TH.
WE WILL TELL YOU WHY THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT SERIOUS ABOUT
PREVENTING SOMETHING LIKE THIS
FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN.
JUST LIKE THEY IGNORED THE RIOT
IN 2020.
THEY ARE MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
OKAY.
TELL THAT TO THE THOUSANDS AND
INJURED COPS, THE DOZENS OF DEA
AMERICANS AND THE BILLIONS IN
PROPERTY DAMAGE THAT PEOPLE
SUFFERED.
DEMOCRATS WILL PURPOSEFULLY OMI
DETAILS ON WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
SIXTH AND BEFORE THE SIXTH.
WE WILL GIVE YOU THOSE DETAILS
THAT YOU LIKELY NEVER HEARD
BEFORE AND WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUESTS THAT WILL CONFIRM ALL OF
THIS FOR YOU.
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN ALL OF THIS.
BUT FIRST, JOE BIDEN IS BACK
FROM THE BEACH.
HE IS SEETHING WITH RAGE TONIGHT
.
NOT BECAUSE OF RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES, WHICH HAVE NOW MORE THA
DOUBLED IN JUST 18 MONTHS UNDER
HIS WATCH.
HE IS NOT SEETHING BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM
BACKBREAKING OF A 42 YEAR RECOR
HIGH OF INFLATION AND LOOMING
RECESSION.
NOT BECAUSE THE BORDER CRISIS,
WHICH IS GETTING WORSE EVERY DAY
.
AND BY THE WAY, AS WE SPEAK, TH
BIGGEST CARAVAN TO DATE IS NOW
APPROACHING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
BUCKLE UP.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT JOE HAS
SIMPLY TURNED THE PAGE ON OUR
TOTAL AMERICANS TRAPPED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WE WILL HIT THE NUMBER 300 THIS
WEEK IF YOU ARE COUNTING LIKE W
ARE.
IT IS DAY 296 SINCE JOE ABANDON
FELLOW AMERICANS BEHIND ENEMY
LINES AND CONFIRMED TWO WEEKS
AGO BY TONY BLINKEN.
AS WE SPEAK, JOE BIDEN IS
SEEMINGLY UNCONCERNED WITH ANY
OF THESE SERIOUS CRISES AND HE
IS DOING NOTHING TO RESOLVE ANY
OF THEM.
INSTEAD, BIDEN IS THROWING A
PITY PARTY FOR HIMSELF BECAUSE
HE IS POLLING LOWER THAN DONALD
TRUMP AND MANY ARE NOW BEGINNIN
TO COMPARE HIM TO JIMMY CARTER
OR EVEN WORSE.
WITH THE MIDTERMS FAST
APPROACHING, DEMOCRATS HAVE
NOTHING CONSTRUCTIVE TO RUN ON.
NOTHING.
THEIR PRESIDENT AND POLICIES,
THE RADICAL GREEN NEW DEAL
AGENDA ARE ALL MASSIVE FAILURES.
DEMOCRATS ARE EMPLOYING WHAT IS
A DESPERATE MULTIPRONGED
POLITICAL STRATEGY FOR THE
UPCOMING ELECTION.
JANUARY 6TH AS PART OF IT.
BUT FIRST, THEY ARE PLANNING TO
SCARE THE VOTERS WITH A HEAVY
DOSE OF HYSTERIA SURROUNDING
ABORTION.
IF ROE V. WADE IS ULTIMATELY
OVERTURNED BY THE SUPREME COURT
WE HAVE EVERY INDICATION THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
DEMOCRATS WILL GO OUT AND
CAMPAIGN THAT A WOMAN'S RIGHT T
CHOOSE HAS BEEN ABOLISHED IN
AMERICA.
ABORTIONS ARE ILLEGAL AND
REPUBLICANS ARE TO BLAME.
THEY WILL VOTE COAT HANGERS AND
BOWEL VALVE BACK ALLEY ABORTIONS
.
THEY WILL CLAIM THAT AMERICA AS
WE NOW KNOW IT IS OVER.
NONE OF THAT WILL BE TRUE.
ABORTION IS NOT AN ENUMERATED
RIGHT IN OUR CONSTITUTION.
BUT IF ROE V. WADE IS OVERTURNE
AS IT APPEARS IT MAY BE IT WILL
BE REGULATED BY INDIVIDUAL
STATES PER THE TENTH AMENDMENT
TO THE CONSTITUTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, ALMOST ALL U.S.
STATE'S WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW
ABORTION WITH VERY LIBERAL
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA, ET
CETERA, LIKELY ALLOWING ABORTIO
UP UNTIL THE MOMENT OF BIRTH
WHICH WE WOULD CALL ON THIS
PROGRAM INFANTICIDE.
THE SECOND PROBLEM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC DEMOCRATIC ELECTION
STRATEGY FOR THE MIDTERMS
SURROUNDS GUNS AND THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
AS WE SPEAK DEMOCRATS ARE
VILIFYING LAW-ABIDING GUN OWNERS
.
THEY ARE AFTER GUN MANUFACTURER
AND THE NRA.
THEY ARE BOWING TO RESTRICT YOU
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THIS TOO IS A STRATEGY THAT I
PREDICT WILL FAIL.
DON'T FORGET ACCORDING TO THE
CDC THERE ARE UP TO 2.5 MILLION
DEFENSIVE GUN USES EACH YEAR.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY SAVE LIVES.
FOR EXAMPLE, OVER THE WEEKEND A
WEST VIRGINIA WOMAN HEROICALLY
SHOT AND KILLED A GUNMAN WHO IS
FIRING INTO A GRADUATION PARTY
AT AN APARTMENT COMPLEX AND SHE
IS NOW BEING CREDITED WITH
SAVING PERHAPS 20 OR 30 LIVES.
BUT OF COURSE THE MEDIA MOB AND
THE DEMOCRATS WILL NOT TALK
ABOUT OR REPORT THAT INCIDENT.
IF DEMOCRATS GET THEIR WAY, ONL
THE CRIMINALS WHO DON'T CARE
ABOUT LAWS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THE FIRE ARMS AND WE WILL ALL B
DEFENSELESS.
ULTIMATELY THE FEAR MONGERING
SURROUNDING GUNS IS LITTLE MORE
THAN A POLITICAL PLOY AND WE
HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO TALK ABOUT
IN A MIDTERM ELECTION YEAR AND
ALL THE POLICIES HAVE FAILED.
I GUESS IT'S A HAIL MARY FOR
THEM.
DEMOCRATS CARED ABOUT GUN
CONTROL AND WOULD CALL ON THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN SUN HUNTER BIDE
TO BE PROSECUTED.
HUNTER REPORTEDLY LIED ON HIS
BACKGROUND CHECK ABOUT HIS
RAMPANT DRUG USE IN ORDER TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM.
THAT WOULD BE A FELONY.
HUNTER'S GUN WAS THROWN AWAY IN
AN GROCERY STORE DUMPSTER ACROS
FROM A HIGH SCHOOL FOR REASONS
NOBODY SEEMS TO KNOW.
AND NOW WE HAVE PICTURES THAT
HAVE SURFACED TODAY SHOWING
HUNTER WAVING AROUND A
SEMIAUTOMATIC HANDGUN WHILE
NAKED ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK
POST.
THEY ARE SAYING POSSIBLY WITH A.
WE CANNOT CONFIRM THAT PART.
BUT JUST IMAGINE IF HIS LAST
NAME WAS HUNTER TRUMP WHAT THE
REACTION IN THE MEDIA AND WHAT
THE REACTION FROM THE DEMOCRATS
WOULD BE.
THE BIDEN'S WANT TO LECTURE US
ON RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERSHIP.
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE A
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERSHIP TO YOU
, JOE?
SHOULD YOUR SON GO TO JAIL OR
MAYBE I WILL SAY IT IN A WAY YO
UNDERSTAND.
FOR GOD SAKES, JOE, CAN'T YOU D
SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR OWN SUN?
>>> THIS BRINGS US TO THE THIRD
PRONG OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SELECTION STRATEGY, WHICH AS YO
CAN PROBABLY GUESS IS JANUARY
6TH, 2021,.
THEY HAVE THIS BIG HEARING SET
FOR THURSDAY.
YOU WILL NOT HEAR THE REAL STOR
OF JANUARY SIXTH ANYWHERE I
DON'T THINK EXCEPT HERE.
AND YOU DEFINITELY WON'T HEAR
FROM HOUSE DEMOCRATS OR THE TWO
REPUBLICANS THAT ARE DEMOCRATS
ON THE COMMITTEE.
REMEMBER, THEY KICKED OFF JIM
JORDAN AND JIM BANKS.
THEY WOULD HAVE ASKED QUESTIONS
LIKE WE HAVE BEEN ASKING AND
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN TO THE TRUTH.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THEIR CONDUCT
SURROUNDING THAT FATEFUL DAY IS
PURE POLITICAL THEATER.
RIGHT ON CUE, THIS THURSDAY
NIGHT THE SHAM JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE WILL BE HOLDING
THEIR BIG PRIMETIME SHOW HEARING
, A FULL ON HOLLYWOOD
MULTIMEDIA EXTRAVAGANZA WITH OF
COURSE HOLLYWOOD CREATIVE
LICENSE TO EMBELLISH, OMIT AND
AS DESIRED.
THEY HAVE EVEN PROCURED